salut à tous aujourd'hui j'ai une grande
nouvelle on vient de dépasser les 100
mille abonnés sur la chaîne youtube
en plus d'être une bonne nouvelle c'est
surtout un mensonge ce qui est vrai
c'est que le mercredi c'est le jour des
astuces et qu'aujourd'hui je vous donne
trois astuces pour détecter un menteur
premièrement le regard il ya une
croyance populaire qui dit que quand
quelqu'un vous regarde bien dans les
yeux c'est qu'il dit la vérité c'est
complètement l'inversé complètement
anormal que le regard soit figé en fait
quand quelqu'un vous regarde droit dans
les yeux tout le temps tout le temps on
lui parle en tout cas il ya de fortes
chances que cette personne là sont en
train de mentir un menteur en train de
proférer son mensonge vous regarde droit
dans les yeux d'une part pour avoir
l'air francs et d'autre part pour
vérifier que vous gobez son mensonge en
fait ils essayent de voir sur votre
visage si vous êtes en train de croire
en ce qu'il dit ou si vous êtes en train
de douter non je vous jure que je fume
pas c'était un pote qui était avec moi
et du coup c'est pour ça que je sens la
fumée de cigarette parce que lui à la la
qu'est-ce qui fume c'est tout il fait
froid aujourd'hui un autre signe du
mensonge très pertinent c'est la
position du regard que la personne en
train de vous parler en fait quand on
raconte une histoire quelque chose qui
s'est passé à quelqu'un on est obligé de
replonger dans ses souvenirs il ya des
positions très précises qui nous sont a
pris par la pnl via la programmation
neuro linguistique imaginer des
pointillés sur mon visage je pourrais
les faire mais j'ai pas envie de frotter
après cette partie là de mon visage mais
correspondent à ce qu'on appelle la
créativité cette partie là va
correspondent à ma mémoire si mes yeux
vont en haut à gauche
donc en haut à droite pour vous qui me
regardent et c'est que je suis dans le
visuel souvenir c'est à dire que je
cherche un souvenir visuel dans ma tête
essayez par exemple de visualiser les
vêtements que vous aviez hier sur vous
et instinctivement votre regard va
monter en haut à gauche pour aller
chercher ce souvenir visuel mais si mon
regard était parti en haut à droite
longue en haut à gauche pour vous qui me
regarder ça aurait voulu dire que
j'étais en train de créer un souvenir
visuel dont quelque chose qui n'existe
pas si par exemple vous demande
d'imaginer une girafe volante à pois
bleus pour vous la représenter va
falloir vous que vous créiez l'image
dans votre cerveau donc vous allez aller
chercher par là où pour les sons c'est
pareil mais ça marche sur une ligne
droite juste ici ça veut dire que je
suis en train de me rappeler un sommet
si sa part de ce côté là est toujours en
ligne droite ça veut dire que je suis en
train de créer un son dans ma tête un
son que je ne connaissais pas ou un son
qui n'existent pas voir même une
conversation qui n'a jamais existé ce
qui se passe en bas du visage après n'a
rien à voir avec le mensonge si je
regarde juste comme ça en fait on oublie
que c'est que je suis sur un dialogue
interne qui est en train par exemple de
réfléchir à ce que je vais répondre de
ce côté là on est sur le kinesthésique
c'est à dire que je suis en train de
ressentir une émotion une sensation ces
genres de choses
l'ensemble est très intéressant parce
que quand quelqu'un vous raconte amant
son jeu tout n'est pas mensonger dans
son histoire sa part souvent d'une
vérité et il ya des éléments par contre
qu'ils sont complètement faux après il
ya les gros mytho qui raconte une
histoire fausse de a à z mais tous les
mouvements oculaires qui va se passer
vous allez pouvoir les traduire pour
voir si ça colle en fait avec l'histoire
ou détecter quel endroit précisément la
personne en train de mentir résumé vous
allez apprécier mes talents de
dessinateur ça c'est certain voici un
visage qui est juste en face de vous si
les yeux vont par là c'est qu'on est sur
du visuel mémoire a réussi ses deux
l'auditif mémoire ici on est sur un
dialogue interne s'il regarde par là on
est sûr de la sensation du ressenti de
ce côté là on est sur un auditifs créé
par en haut on est sur un visuel créé la
dernière méthode c'est pas pour détecter
le mensonge c'est pour piéger le menteur
si vous pensez que la personne est en
train de mentir mais que vous n'êtes pas
certains 100 % malgré les deux
techniques précédente
ou si vous voulez mettre le moteur mal à
l'aise et lui prouver qu'il est en train
de mentir la technique ultime pour ça
vous lui demander de raconter la même
histoire le même mensonge mais à
l'envers de la faim jusqu au début comme
le moteur est en train de créer son
histoire au fur et à mesure et trouve
une logique dans l'histoire dans ce sens
là il va s'en rappeler plus ou moins il
va être capable de la ressortir par
contre c'est impossible pour lui de
faire d'une manière fluide et à l'envers
n'y allez pas comme une brute non plus
vous pouvez juste poser des questions il
s'était passé quoi à la fin à oui
d'accord et juste avant oui ok mais mais
toi tu es tu arrivé quand et vous allez
vraiment voir la galère et le stress sur
la personne si la personne était en
train de vous mentir
de toute manière vous allez voir à quel
point elle est en galère à quel point
elle est stressée dr house se disait
tout le monde ment bon c'est pas
complètement faux on fait tous des
petits mensonges au quotidien donc n'en
voulait jamais trop quelqu'un qui vous a
menti si c'est un mensonge juste pour
enjoliver un petit peu sa vie etc
c'est pas bien grave après c'est
différent si c'est quelque chose qui
vous créez une embrouille avoue bien sûr
ne va pas se mentir si cette astuce vous
a plu vous mettez un petit pouce en
l'air et puis voilà ça c'est sincère et
vous pouvez vous abonner évidemment ou
commenter je lis tous les commentaires
tous 12-12 tout le temps plus ça va plus
je lis des commentaires demain pour la
vidéo de jeudi ce que je veux je vais
vous parler d'un sosie apparemment je
suis le sosie de quelqu'un je les ai
pris dans les commentaires récemment je
suis allé voir ça m'a rempli de douleur
parce que c'est vrai je vous fais une
annonce à la fin de la vidéo pour le
live qu'on va organiser d'ici là portez
vous bien rendez vous demain à 17 heures
pour le prochain mentale blog ciao
le mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an tous les jours je mets une
vidéo pendant un an j'ai commencé le 1er
janvier je finirai le 31 décembre
j'avais un objectif à 2500 abonnés
convient de cramer puisqu'on est arrivé
à 9000 abonnés depuis que pierre cros a
invité à faire une vidéo avec lui ai
jamais dit casse de 2500 abonnés on fera
un live tous ensemble donc je me suis
dit ok on va tous se rejoindre sur la
page facebook fabien olicard on fera le
live et je viens de découvrir carlyle
facebook ça ne peut faire que 30 minutes
donc c'est pas hyper intéressant j'ai
donc porté mon choix sur périscope donc
vous pouvez me rajouter sur twitter ou
sur périscope c'est fabien olicard toute
attache et surtout mes réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs et ce samedi le samedi 2
avril à 16 heures je lance le live
dément pas l'eau pour pouvoir prendre le
temps de discuter on peut parler de la
chaîne on peut parler du mentalisme peut
parler des spectacles on peut parler de
n'importe quoi en fait n'importe quoi le
but c'est qu'on se retrouve pour pas de
rater vous pouvez déjà vous rajouter sur
périscope ou sur twitter directement ou
sur facebook aussi puisque je
rajouterais le lien sur la fanpage voilà
c'était la fin de l'annoncé